Hello, everyone.
I'm Shreyas Doshi.
I'm a product manager
here at Google.
And I work on various
parts of AdWords,
including the AdWords API.
So let's get started.
Today, I want to basically
leave you with three key
messages with regards
to the AdWords API.
The first one is that we've
actually been very busy since
we launched the AdWords API.
But the key thing I wanted you
guys to walk away with, key
message, is that you need to
start taking advantage of
these new features.
We've actually taken into
account a lot of your feedback
and incorporated that in these
new versions of the API.
Second is that since we've
launched these versions of the
API, it basically implies that
the old versions of the API
had to go away.
And so there's a migration
coming up.
For instance, we are going to
start sunsetting the remainder
of v13 and v200909 as these
new versions launch.
And the third key message is
that, while we've improved the
API, we realize that there are
a lot of other problems that
you face that aren't
yet addressed.
So let's start with what's
new with the AdWords API.
The first one is preferred
AdWords API pricing.
So that is something we launched
for agencies and SEMs
in May of this year.
Preferred pricing is a way in
which you can get basically
unlimited use of the API.
So it's an application
process.
You apply with us.
And then as long as you meet
certain requirements, we will
basically give you unlimited
use of the API for free.
Second one is v13 is gone.
It's not really gone.
It's almost gone.
There are about three services
that remain.
And so I will talk about what
we're going to do with those
three services.
And the third is we've launched
v201003, as well as
v201008 more recently.
And so let's look at the new
features that we've released
in these versions.
So the first one, and the one
that I'm very excited about,
is the ReportService.
So this is the new version
of the ReportService.
The key thing about this
version is that it's
significantly faster than
the v13 ReportService.
Because it's built on our new
architecture, it will enable
us to expose features much
faster, so expose new fields
much faster than we've done in
past versions of the API.
Second one is these exciting ad
formats, product ads, which
is essentially product listing
ads and product extensions.
And these are actually ads-- and
you see they have images
associated with those
products--
on Google Search.
It's a compelling ad format,
and we launched support for
this in v201008.
Another feature is
remarketing.
This is a very interesting
feature.
And essentially, what it lets
you do is it lets people who
browsed your site, who probably
did not buy something
or basically end up in a
conversion event, it lets you
target those users.
Because by definition they would
be more engaged and more
interested in your products.
And so we've exposed a new
service called the
UserListService, which
essentially lets you target
users and converts browsers
and searchers
into buyers for you.
Bid simulator is a feature which
we launched in v201003.
And we also launched AdGroup,
a big simulator in v201008.
And essentially, what that
lets you do, as the name
indicates, it lets you simulate
what your traffic
might have been for different
values of bids.
Ad sitelinks.
Sitelinks are another compelling
new ad format.
And they look a lot like
just general text ads.
But what you see is they
actually have forward links at
the bottom of the ad.
So what that lets you do is it
no longer limits you to the
landing page or the home page
or whatever it is that you
have in the destination URL.
But you can actually take the
user to specific locations
within your web site and
hopefully get better
conversions that way.
This is a feature that a lot of
advertisers have been very
excited about.
And it's also available
in the API.
Phone extensions.
This is very relevant for, say,
the local use case where
a lot of times advertisers have
told us, look, a click on
my website or for my website
is interesting.
But what I really care about
in some cases is
a call to my business.
And so what this lets you do
is it lets you associate a
phone number with your
ad as an extension.
And with that, you can actually
include that phone
number in the text ad.
And it'll show up when the user
is using a hybrid mobile
device like an iPhone,
for instance.
There's a ton of other
new stuff.
We've launched a new traffic
estimator service.
There are a couple of other
things like enhanced CPC,
target CPA.
And all of the information about
this is available in the
docs, of course, and
also on the blog.
And then we have some
beta features that
we've launched recently.
So one is AdWords Campaign
Experiments.
This is a feature that
advertisers have been asking
for for a very long
time from AdWords.
What it does is it lets you
run live A/B tests.
Basically, instead of trying to
guess what would happen if
you set your bid to a certain
value, you can actually try it
as an A/B test and then see what
performs better and more
in concert with your
advertising goals.
Change history.
This is a feature which
basically lets you download
changes that happened to
specific accounts.
And so in the past, you guys
have told us, look, every
night, I have this job
that downloads the
entire campaign structure.
And sometimes it's a waste
because maybe only a few
things in the campaign have
actually changed.
We've heard that feedback
in the past.
And we have been working on
exposing this service.
What it does is it lets you
query within the API for
specific entities that
have changed.
And so you can say, give me a
list of changes that have
happened since a particular date
or in this time range.
And then it will give you the
IDs of those entities.
And then you can only pull
those entities instead of
pulling your entire
account structure.
And then the last beta feature
is a partial failures support.
The idea is, let's say you
submit 1,000 operations to us.
And 10 of them somehow fail
for one reason or another,
maybe they violate
some policy rule.
Instead of your entire call
failing, what this will do is
it will only fail the
faulty operations.
So this is only exposed in
one service right now.
But over time, we'll start
exposing it in
more and more services.
So again, the key message that
I want to convey is that you
should start using and taking
advantage of these features as
soon as you can.
So when you go back, I would
encourage you to talk to
various people in your
organization and get these
features on your roadmap so
you can take advantage of
better automation, more features
in the API, and more
efficiency.